L
SEEMS VERY ODD, CONSIDERING HOW
SAFE IT IS TO USE FOR AN
EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME.
COUNTRIES LIKE KENYA SET TO RUN
OUT OF COVID VACCINE IN JUST A
FEW DAYS.
THE HEALTH MINISTER SAYS
AFRICAN COUNTRIES MUST NOW
REALIZE IT'S EVERYONE FOR
THEMSELVES.
WE HAVE MORE.
>> THERE ARE KENYANS WHO
RECEIVED THE FIRST DOSE OF THE
ASTRAZENECA VACCINE WHO WILL
NOT HAVE A 2ND DOSE BECAUSE
CANADA'S AND HAVE ANY MORE OF
IT IN A FEW DAYS.
THERE ARE SOME WHO RECEIVED THE
FIRST SHOT OF ASTRAZENECA THAT
MAY BE OFFERED THE SINGLE DOSE
JOHNSON & JOHNSON SHOT WITH
100,000 VACCINES LEFT BY AS
SOON AS FRIDAY.
THE COUNTRY MAY BE OUT OF ANY
MORE VACCINE SHOTS.
THE COUNTRIES TRY TO BRING IN
MORE VACCINES FROM NEIGHBORING
COUNTRIES THAT DOESN'T HAVE A
CAPACITY TO NOT GET ITS
CITIZENS BEFORE THOSE VACCINES
EXPIRE.
THE BIG PROBLEM HERE, THE
CANYON HEALTH MINISTER HAS TOLD
ME VACCINE NATIONALISM WHICH
HAS EXPOSED AFRICA'S INABILITY
TO HAVE ITS OWN VACCINES IN A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
THIS IS WHAT I'VE HEARD.
>> VACCINE NATIONALISM IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS CROPPED UP
ACROSS THE WORLD.
THOSE AS A CONTINENT, WE MUST
STOP BELIEVING THERE'S ANYBODY
OUT THERE WITH A GOOD SAMARITAN,
A BIBLICAL SAMARITAN, WHO'S
ABOUT TO COME AND HELP US.
THERE IS NOTHING LIKE THAT.
YOU KNOW?
THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE WE
HAVE SEEN VERY CLEARLY, IT'S
EVERYONE FOR THEMSELVES, AND
GOOD FOR US ALL.
AND THEREFORE, GOING INTO THE
FUTURE, LOCAL PRODUCTION, LOCAL
MANUFACTURING OR OF
PHARMACEUTICAL COMMODITIES AND
PRODUCTS IS A MUST.
>> HOW BAD IS IT FOR KENYA THAT
THE INSTITUTES SAY ON TUESDAY
THAT IT WILL NOT RESUME VACCINE
SHIPMENTS UNTIL THE END OF THE
YEAR?
>> WE'RE NOT JUST WAITING FOR
THESE DONATIONS THAT ARE COMING
TO KENYA.
WE ARE IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
JOHNSON & JOHNSON FACILITIES IN
SOUTH AFRICA.
FOR WHAT WE THINK IS GOING TO
BE THE NEW SUPPLY CHAIN RATHER
THAN RELYING ON ASTRAZENECA,
GIVEN WHAT'S HAPPENING IN INDIA,
AND GIVEN THE DIFFICULTIES THE
INDIAN PEOPLE ARE GOING THROUGH,
AND THE POPULATION OF INDIA.
IT'S VERY UNLIKELY ASTRAZENECA
IS GOING TO BE THE VACCINE OF
CHOICE FOR THE AFRICAN
CONTINENT GOING FOR.
IT IS VERY LIKELY THAT WE ARE
GOING TO DISCUSS AND AGREE ON
JOHNSON & JOHNSON.
>> THE AFRICAN UNION IS NOW
SAYING IT'S ORDERED 400 MILLION
SHOTS OF THE JOHNSON & JOHNSON
VACCINE, AND IT EXPECTS 20 40
MILLION OF THOSE TO BE
AVAILABLE IN AFRICA THIS YEAR.
EVEN IF THOSE WERE TO COME
THROUGH, THAT STILL A DROP IN
THE OCEAN FOR A CONTINENT OF
ONE BILLION PEOPLE WERE ONLY
ABOUT 2% OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED SO FAR.
IT'LL TAKE TIME UNTIL THE
MAJORITY OF THE ADULT
POPULATION ACROSS THE AFRICAN
CONTINENT IS VACCINATED.
THE CONTINENT IS LOOKING TO
COVAX, AS WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION INITIATIVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO FUND THE
JOHNSON & JOHNSON SHOT.
BUT THINKING ACROSS THE
CONTINENT IS THAT IT CAN'T RELY
ON THE LARGEST MONEY VACCINE
MANUFACTURE BECAUSE IT SAID IT
WON'T BE EXPORTING VACCINES
INTERNATIONALLY UNTIL THE END
OF THE YEAR, BECAUSE OF IN HIS
OWN COVID CRISIS.
ACROSS THE CONTINENT IN NAIROBI,
IN MANY OF THE CITIES, THERE
ARE PEOPLE WONDERING WHEN THEY
WILL HAVE THAT PROTECTION.
IN THE MEANTIME, THERE IS THE
FEAR THAT THE LONGER PEOPLE
REMAIN UNVACCINATED, THE VIRUS
WILL MUTATE.
THERE WILL BE VARIANTS THAT
WILL SPREAD TO THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
AS PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN HAS SAID,
AS COVAX HAS SAID, AS MANY
OFFICIALS ACROSS THE AFRICAN
CONTINENT HAVE SAID, NOBODY IS
SAFE IN ANY PART OF THE WORLD
UNTIL EVERYBODY IS SAFE BECAUSE
THOSE MANUFACTURING REGARDLESS